[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys weltweite
gibt es noch mal ein richtig tolles
ramadan rezept und zwar habe ich ja
schon dieser klassischen rezepte im
prinzip alle durch bagdad haben wir
schon gemacht kündigt tarif und jetzt
habe ich mir gedacht nachdem baklava
czieslik mache normal was machst du zur
saison passt und was man auch noch mal
vorbereiten kann für das ramadanfest für
beide heute gibt es eine erdbeertorte
und ich weiß dass viele weiler
erdbeertorte gerade diese schicht oben
gar nicht mögen diese tortenguss schicht
viele kratzen die er immer weg und heute
habe ich etwas für euch auf euer problem
beseitigt wir machen nämlich später
diese schicht obendrauf mit dem
tortenguss zum sprühen
das zeige ich euch später jetzt zeige
ich erstmal die zutaten für den teig das
ist ein richtig lockerer luftiger früher
öl teig und den bereiten wir jetzt als
erstes zu für den teig verwende ich
feiere 200 gramm zucker etwas vanille
extrakt eine prise salz 125 gramm
sonnenblumenöl 150 gramm orangenlimonade
250 gramm mehl ein päckchen backpulver
und etwas zitrone abrieb ich nehme jetzt
zuerst die eier
die kommen jetzt direkt regierung
schüssel ist echt super einfacher tag
da kommt der zucker mit dazu
das war ein extrakt
und etwas an jetzt werden die zutaten
hier etwa vier bis fünf minuten richtig
cremig verrührt
[Musik]
da kommen jetzt die beiden flüssigkeiten
rein also das öl und die limonade
ich nehme jetzt auch alle monate ihr
könnt aber auch gerne eine andere
limonade nehmen
ein bisschen zitronen abrieb und da
einfach nur darauf achten dass die
zitronenschale auch zum verzehr geeignet
ist und dann kann ich jetzt noch das
mehl mit dem backpulver vermischen und
dann einfach dazu sieben und kurz
einrühren
[Musik]
und dann einfach den teig ihnen
backblech führen ich mache hier mit dem
bug rahmen weil dann der teig einfach
schön gleichmäßig backt und ich brauche
ja später sowieso einen bug rahmen außen
grund für die kritik
es ist echt praktisch weil ich mir dann
wirklich einen arbeitsmaterial sparen
gleichmäßig verteilen und dann im ofen
backen
[Musik]
der boden ist fertig die nehme ich jetzt
herauslassen abkühlen lasst den
torrahmen außen rum und werde jetzt mit
den frühling schon mal herstellen für
den pistazien pudding verwende ich 400
gramm milch 100 gramm pistazien 200
gramm sahne 40 g zucker 60 gramm stärke
2 eigelbe und 400 und ich nehme jetzt
zuerst ein bisschen milch die kommt hier
in den topf mit der restlichen milch
spüre ich jetzt die pistazien damit so
richtig schön fein gemahlen werden
ihr könnt im prinzip auch trocken
pürieren also trocken malen aber so
werden sie ticken feiern
[Musik]
in den topf gebe ich jetzt noch hier die
eigelbe dann die stärke die eigelbe
machen den pudding richtig schön cremig
und bei vanillepudding sorgen sie dafür
dass der pudding einfach eine richtig
schöne gelbe farbe bekommt geht es nach
dem zucker dazugeben und kurz verrühren
schön klümpchen frei und es klappt eben
immer am besten wenn man eine kleine
milchmenge hat daher habe ich jetzt hier
nicht die komplette strecke aber
theoretisch könnte die auch die eigelbe
die stärke oder zucker auch noch mit in
den mixer packen dann wird sowieso alles
glöckchen frei
dann hört sie spät dran gedacht jetzt
einfach die pistazien minister zu gießen
jetzt den herz auf mittel hohe stufe
stellen und während dem röhren den
pudding einmal aufkochen lassen
ach bist du was ich hier noch dazu gebe
die sahne natürlich fast verlierst
und wichtig ist eigentlich nur dass der
pudding eben erst dann angerührt wird
wenn der kuchen boden abgekühlt ist das
heißt ich habe nach dem backen kuchen
boden ein bisschen abkühlen lassen und
dann höre ich jetzt eben erst im pudding
an
[Musik]
mach ich es lecker ende hoops müsst ihr
aufpassen weil ich gerade wagen habe ich
vertrag hat und am ende darauf passen
damit wirklich am topfboden nichts
anklebt deswegen rühre ich immer und
stellt auch den herren nicht so hoch
damit einfach unten der pudding nicht
anbrennt jetzt hats club gemacht
effekt kann ich den pudding vom herd
herunterziehen jetzt den pudding um
einfach eine andere schüssel damit ich
besser rühren kann und damit eben nicht
so heiß bleibt die farbe unterbruch sind
echte habe ich meine jetzt sagt ich bin
kein christ ac entfernt dann lass dir
die pistazie einfach weg das verändert
sich nichts als ihr müsst nichts
ergänzen oder gesetzen einfach
rauslassen
aber vielleicht können wir dann ein
bisschen wandel extrakte oder zb
zitronenschale dazugeben kurz berühren
und hier kommt jetzt das meint dazu der
könnten pudding jetzt auch direkt ein
bisschen runter und macht ihn einfach
etwas frischer urteil ich hier die
gräben immer schön gleichmäßig also
nicht auf einen fleck es wird nämlich
diese eine fleck richtig eingedrückt
durch das gewicht der creme
das sind so fehler die macht nur einmal
und dann nie wieder habe ich nämlich
auch schon gemacht und jetzt einfach
schön gleichmäßig verstreichen und dann
den kuchen kalt stellen damit die
putting green fest und schön kalt und
dann kommt da nur noch die sahne creme
und später die etwas schicht drauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit dem enkeltrick die pink ribbon ist
jetzt richtig schön kalt da kommt jetzt
noch die sahne schicht drauf dafür
verwende ich viele gramm sahne etwas
vanille extrakt und salat nehme ich
einfach eine große schüssel
da kommt die sahne rein manuell extrakt
als geschmack dazu und dann einfach mit
seiner partei schlagen
[Musik]
bis dieser fertig muss man aufpassen
dass man sie nicht über schlägt jetzt
nehme ich einfach das blech und streich
jetzt hier die sache draus
ich habe jetzt auch gar nicht gesucht
ich denke die süße aus den früchten die
reicht jetzt vollkommen aus wenn ja wann
habt die noch nicht so süß sind dann
könnt ihr gerne ein bisschen butter
zucker dazugeben zusammen wenn ihr
braucht unsere at wenn die kommen
nämlich vom bauern klaus pesch aus
reilingen und da holen was ihr selbst
sonntags kann man da hin
wir können klaus fragen warum seine
erdbeeren so gut und hilft es dort los
jetzt heraus warum sind eine erdbeere
den lakers die beste also meine erdbeere
oder unsere erdbeeren sind die läger
schnitt um diebe schnell weil sie
nachhaltig produziert wäre im einklang
mit der natur
aber außerdem sollte die auch nach
erdbeeren schmecken fruchtig und süßen
und dann kümmern wir uns halt täglich
und unserer pflanzen was denn auch gut
jetzt die sahne hier das schön verteilen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und wenn ihr die torte jetzt nicht heute
gleich verzehren wollt dann deckt sie
jetzt ab und stellt sie in den
kühlschrank und am nächsten tag könnt
ihr dann die erdbahn schneiden frisch
drauf legen und dann mit dem tortenguss
cray einfach fertig stellen ich finde es
nämlich immer ganz lecker wenn der ferne
ganz frisch aufgeschnitten sind also mir
persönlich sprechen sie am nächsten tag
aufgeschnitten nicht mehr so bot der
sind aber geschmackssache sie halten auf
jeden fall und das tortenguss bringt das
isoliert das ganze auch und schützt die
erdbeeren also die werden nicht schlecht
das ist für mich nur eine
geschmackssache
ich werde heute das ganze blech jetzt zu
bereiten gibt die torte ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank und kann schon mal die
erdbeeren vorbereiten
ansonsten wie gesagt könnte auch jetzt
alles fertig stellen und einfach in den
kühlschrank stellen nur mag ich's frisch
am liebsten
ich habe jetzt die erdbeeren bereits
gewaschen und ich zeige euch hier mal
zwei sorten und zwar hat mir die wvs
mitgegeben hier habe ich einmal die
sorte lambada und einmal die sorte clary
die sorte lambada ist wirklich die gummi
erdbeere die hat wirklich einen richtig
intensiven vollen geschmack sie völlig
aber auch relativ schnell an geschmack
das heißt wenn die geerntet wird beim
klaus werden sie immer ganz früh am
morgen geerntet dann sollte man sie
wirklich am gleichen oder spätestens am
nächsten tag noch essen weil ansonsten
der richtig tolle geschmack verloren
geht
die eignen sich auch ganz gut für
allergiker die vertragen die besonders
gut und sie sind wirklich schön süß ich
kann daraus auch ganz gut und der
marmelade kochen zum beispiel und die
sind aber auch kuchen und torten nicht
so gut weil sie einfach wie gesagt an
geschmack deutschland verliert und ihr
seht auch die sehen dann auch relativ
schnell matschig aus schmecken aber
wirklich hervorragend also wirklich die
beste erdbeere die man essen kann und
hier habe ich noch die sorte und zwar
ist es die sorte clary und die sind
etwas fester
auch aromatisch und wirklich sehr lecker
aber diesen weg verfolgen ob kuchen und
torten geeignet weil sie sehr lange
halten und eben nicht so schnell
matschig werden also die halten sich
wenn ich die beim klaus hol' schon
locker eine woche im kühlschrank also
theoretisch fragt es nicht weil
ein bisschen zu schnell auch jetzt
einfach nur den strunk entfernen und
ganz ganz minimal wegschneiden damit die
erdbeeren stehen können ich setze jetzt
nämlich gleich in scheiben schneiden
guckt mal mit dem rapido wird es
wirklich richtig schön gleichmäßig so
ist jede erdbeer schreibe gleich dick
ihr müsst einfach einmal mit schwung
richtig schön schneiden also nicht zu
quetschen
dann werden die erdbeeren richtig die
vor allem sehr schnell
er ist die torte herauslösen stalin war
es doch ziemlich einfach oder
und danach wird nicht komplizierter es
bleibt einfach vor allem liebe ich
blechkuchen weil man einfach gleich eine
große menge hat und man kann sie einfach
beliebig zu schneiden also wenn nach
unten torte ist immer schwieriger kleine
stücke zu schneiden
aber bei einer eckigen torte geht es
wunderbar nämlich einen paten retter sie
die torte jetzt darauf die folie
darunter weg ich möchte jetzt auch noch
nicht die komplette torte servieren
deswegen werde ich jetzt auch erstmal
nur einen teil belegen
ich mag ihren jetzt die stelle und
schneit es auch schon mal weg ich mache
später 5 x 5 cm oder sechsmal 15 -
stücke
[Musik]
den teil belege ich jetzt mit erdbeeren
wie lege ich jetzt hier so etwas
schwächer förmlich auf die sahne hilft
dabei dass die app dann später nicht von
der torte runter rutschen
denn ich habe ja keinen tortenguss
drückt jetzt die erdbeeren so ein
bisschen an
da ist ja auch die samen geschichte wenn
jetzt ganz normal mit tortenguss
arbeitet würde ich die sache schlicht
weglassen weil sie nämlich durch den
warmen tortenguss aufschmelzen kann ich
arbeite jetzt aber mit dem portikus prey
und das ist wirklich super praktisch ich
muss nicht erwärmen ich muss nicht
erhitzen nichts berühren das kann nichts
kleben und anbrennen und vor allem ist
es sofort stuhl bereit das heißt auch
wenn ihr dann sagt ich möchte meine
torte und meine früchte erst später
drauf setzen könnt ihr einfach jederzeit
kleine portionen besprühen ohne dass er
später was übrig habt als ihr könnt auch
theoretisch so mache ich mach zwei
erdbeertorte aber ihr könnt auch die
schnitten zu lassen
schneiden und dann zb mit air berlin
bern brombeeren oder welchen früchten
auch immer belegen und dann einfach auf
dem teller besprühen das geht auch
hier seht ihr jetzt die advents in netz
geschnitten dass die werde im prinzip
auch anfällig und würden jetzt
theoretisch in den nächsten paar minuten
zu matschen und dieses tortenguss spray
das schützt jetzt die erdbeeren vor dem
austrocknen und vor dem schlecht werden
hat jetzt einfach vorher gut
durchschütteln und dann für drauf geben
man sieht auch direkt in glanz und es
wird eben auch direkt fest und hier
spreche ich jetzt einfach nur so viel
drauf dass alle erdmann bedeckt sind das
heißt ich habe diese dicke gummiartige
tortenguss sicht gar nicht mehr bei uns
in der familie hat die immer gar keiner
gegessen weil es keiner mochte und hier
hat man es einfach gar nicht also
wirklich ganz sparsam dosieren ich drauf
geben habe mich schön ins land nicht
geschmeckt vor allem einfach ganz mal
tragen
ich stelle die kurz in den kühlschrank
und dann können die jungs vom zum
probieren kommen und die übrige torte
die denke ich dann ab und nachts nicht
für morgen oder abend oder wann auch
immer okay jetzt schneide ich kleine
stückchen zu dann darf das jemand
probieren eigentlich wollten die jungs
grad in die mittagspause oder gesagt
sehr mag es gibt erdbeertorte später
kommt noch ein stück zum nachtisch
erwartet noch kurz das jetzt aber ohne
pudding lobend wurde ja ohne sind
tortenguss marshals normalerweise bei
app betroffen diese schichtungen raum
das muss nicht sein aber wenn es
manchmal zu viel ist dann was auch immer
ich finde mich das hatte keinen
geschmack
ja es ist gut mit wasser mit zucker ja
das ist nur was anderes wasser zucker so
kann sagt nehmen aber die wenigsten
machen nur wasser zucker und sahne
spektiv drin oder gelatine das ist mir
sowieso viele nicht ja jetzt habe ich ja
was anderes für dich ich habe natürlich
ganz dünnen tortenguss zum sprühen drauf
das ist eigentlich dürfte normalerweise
nur die erdbeeren dran herausschmecken
und unten habe ich also teig dann
pistazien pudding sahne und erdbeeren
[Musik]
ich habe mir gedacht pistazien es passt
einfach ramada stadien
ich bin besser als mit der ausstellung
gehen soll
finde ich super sehr gut und auch die
sahne ist nicht du siehst also es passt
nämlich ohne ca dieser reicht mir
gedacht die der zucker reicht
wahrscheinlich für verträglicher zu
rufen staaten pudding bisschen und ja
kommt drauf an ob ihr gute art beim 100
und wie gesagt könnt ihr das so super
vorbereiten und ihr könnt ihr dann auch
andere früchte drauflegen was sie eben
beachten müsst das wenn ihr das torten
cosplay benutzt der tortenguss thema
normalerweise drauf schüttet werk lebt
ja immer die etwa noch zusammen also da
fällt ja dann nichts runter und hier
muss man praktisch die erdbahn erstmal
in die creme so ein bisschen rein
drücken dann ein bisschen eisspray drauf
als macht eben schneiden möchte oder
auch einfach eine andere schicht runter
ja ich finde es schöner aus ja ja ja ich
finde das sieht man doch raus von
melbourne
und wie gesagt die steht jetzt schon
zeit nach studium gefällt im kühlschrank
und passt super standfest und richtig
schön läuft nichts weg vielen dank fürs
verkosten ganz gern macht damit als 1000
stück gehen würde also falls ihr das
rezept nach macht dann gerne auf cds -
blog.de dacia und da steht es noch mal
für euch ihr könnt auch gerne durch
meine umrechnung tabelle auf dem blog
durch die umrechnung funktion einfach
das ganze in eine runde springform
umrechnen lassen geht auch aber ich
finds abschnitten eigentlich auch immer
ganz praktisch also viel spaß beim
nachbarkind und bis zum nächsten mal
beide waren die begriffe zum teil direkt
[Musik]
das schlusswort coole bauernregeln
schieß los also eine qualitativ
hochwertige erdbeere muss man gucken und
nicht reichen legen und nicht schmeißen
nach perrys wir richtig heimisch und das
hab ich sogar verstanden
jetzt wissen wir es